de devenir nombreux pour cette
audition merci à mes collègues aussi de
leur présence et à notre à nos
administrateurs pour cette audition
concernant la mission que nous menons
Sénat sur la gestion durable de l'eau
c'est une mission
d'information transportable comme on le
fait habituellement au Sénat c'est à
dire que tous les groupes politiques ils
sont représentés et c'était à la demande
du groupe socialiste
et dans le rapporteur et mon ami
Hervé gilet sénateur de Gironde
qui donc vous posera un certain nombre
de questions
je crois que vous avez reçu et
d'ailleurs un questionnaire
assez complet
vous aurez bien sûr la possibilité de
faire une contribution écrite
au-delà de cette audition parce qu'on
aura peut-être pas le temps de tout
analyser donc merci d'avance de de
pouvoir le faire avant disons
avant le 15 juin c'était possible parce
que notre objectif c'est de déposer de
notre rapport début juillet donc on
voudrait que les choses se complètent à
ce moment-là donc
[Musique]
il s'agit de d'entendre tous les experts
et tous les toutes les parties prenantes
acteurs institutionnels de la politique
de l'eau
c'est vrai que le changement climatique
est là avec des années très sèches 2022
était une année très sèche 2023 on
risque d'avoir peut-être une année pire
que que la précédente avec des nappes
phréatiques qui ne se remplissent pas
aujourd'hui donc nous allons
vous entendre comme acteur de
l'hydroélectricité
parce que l'eau évidemment c'est
l'alimentation humaine
c'est l'eau potable c'est l'agriculture
mais c'est aussi l'énergie
et je pense que on a besoin aussi de
concilier les deux
et donc on attend de vous de savoir
comment vous voyez les choses sur le le
marché de l'hydroélectricité dans un
contexte qui nécessite à la fois une
gestion
quantitative et qualitative
efficiente de la ressource en eau
d'autre part quels sont vos
préconisations également pour une
meilleure adéquation entre la
rentabilité économique mais aussi la
continuité
écologique quels sont vos expériences
respectives parce qu'on a besoin aussi
de vous retours et quels sont si vos
propositions bien évidemment dans le
domaine de la gestion de durable de
l'eau aujourd'hui
on voit bien qu'on peut faire aussi de
de l'électricité avec des chutes d'eau
qui sont plus faibles que qu'auparavant
donc
[Musique]
la micro
hydroélectricité est une
source qui peut être mise en place dans
certains secteurs donc mais tout en
respectant un certain nombre de
conditions avec les problématiques
des tirages de nos rivières et puis
problématique de qualité de l'eau donc
voilà vous avez
vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer et je
vais laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur Hervé gilet juste peut-être
se refaire un tour de de des acteurs
donc nous avons madame Emmanuel verger
directrice de DF hydro
et Monsieur Bruno de charger
qui est derrière en charge des relations
institutionnelles la société
hydroélectrique du Midi
avec Monsieur Cyril Delprat directeur
général la Compagnie nationale du Rhône
madame Laurence Bory Bancel le président
du directoire
France hydroélectricité
donc
alors Monsieur Monsieur Lévy
voilà on avait vu Christine qui était
annoncé Christine etchegoïen ancienne
présidente et Cécile Bellot qui est
derrière là-bas et la Fédération des
moulins de France Monsieur Alain ekem et
président et Monsieur Michel landreux
administrateur donc voilà tout le monde
est là et présent Hervé je te laisse la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Cherry pour ses propos introductifs je
remercie aussi mes collègues d'être
présents pour cette table ronde
particulièrement importante
on est dans un moment vraiment
particulier il est particulier parce que
la
conjoncture
fait que ce sujet prend une résonance
particulière
et donc c'est sans doute le moment ou
jamais
d'approfondir les sujets et de voir si
éventuellement nous pouvons faire des
propositions et pourquoi pas d'autres
législatives
d'actualité parce que bien sûr il y aura
les déclarations du président aussi
aujourd'hui et on mettra
ces propositions en perspective au
regard bien sûr des travaux que nous
avons déjà menés mais qui nous reste
effectivement à mener puisqu'on se situe
à peu près amis parcours nous devrions
rendre notre rapport pour mi-juillet
avec donc une rédaction qui va commencer
déjà mi-juin à peu près et donc nous
avons déjà réalisé un peu plus d'une
vingtaine d'auditions donc nous allons
bien évidemment
approfondir un certain nombre de sujets
comme vous l'avez compris on est bien
sur l'ensemble des six grands cycles et
petits cycles de l'eau même si
aujourd'hui le fait de les distinguer de
plus en plus discuter en
de regarder d'un peu plus près les
gouvernances territoriales le fait
d'avoir une connaissance de plus en plus
approfondie de l'évolution de la
ressource et de la nécessité de disposer
de base de données qui soient de plus en
plus fiable mais derrière la ressource
c'est bien sûr d'y adapter la
consommation à l'échelle évidemment des
bassins mais en travaillant les
subsidiarités de manière la plus forte
possible l'acceptabilité des projets est
aussi majeur bien sûr dans les
interrogations que nous pouvons avoir et
la gestion des pratiques en essayant
d'imaginer aussi des scénarios qui nous
permettraient de contribuer à la
sobriété nécessaire aujourd'hui et
demain mais je pense que le Président de
la République aura aussi des Annonces
particulières vous êtes donc des acteurs
majeurs dans dans sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets et donc nous sommes
particulièrement intéressés de pouvoir
vous écouter aujourd'hui ce que je vous
propose c'est en reprenant l'ordre de
présentation du président de faire
peut-être une première introduction on
va balayer ensuite avec l'ensemble
des représentants donc d'abord peut-être
les les reprécisions sur les grandes
données et
hydroélectriques et vos implications
personnelles au regard de vos
responsabilités et puis après on lancera
aussi le questionnement en essayant
d'être le plus interactif possible pour
qu'on puisse avoir un bon niveau
d'échange et puis nos collègues bien sûr
pourront aussi intervenir et vous poser
un certain nombre de questions merci
alors je vous demande de faire trois
minutes
chacun pas plus parce que si vous voulez
un temps qui est imparti et puis nos
collègues auront des questions à vous
poser le rapporteur encore des
précisions à vous demander donc essayons
d'être le plus concis possible donc
merci de respecter les les trois minutes
merci Madame berger
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur merci beaucoup d'abord pour
cette invitation à venir intervenir
devant vous aujourd'hui madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénatrice
bonjour mesdames messieurs bonjour à
tous moi je voudrais commencer quand
même alors vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur aujourd'hui il y
a une vallée qui va être qui a été
choisie par le Président de la
République et par et par le gouvernement
pour faire cette annonce du plan haut
qui est une en plus une région moi qui
m'est cher et je trouve qui est un
exemple à bien avoir en tête
en termes de
multi-usage de l'eau et ce qu'on peut
faire avec des ouvrages hydroélectriques
mais qui ne font pas que ça alors cette
vallée enfin cette C valait pardon ce
sont évidemment c'est les vallées de la
Durance du Verdon et puis également du
Buchet de la Bléone qui sont peut-être
un petit peu moins connus avec des
premières ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est qu'en fait c'est dès le milieu du
16ème siècle que ce concept de
construction de d'équipements
dédiés aux multi-usages de l'eau à
commencer à
commencé à apparaître voilà l'idée
c'était évidemment d'amener une partie
des eaux de la Provence jusqu'à
Marseille pour alimenter les villes en
eau pour arroser les terrains pour
irriguer enfin c'était pas encore
d'irrigation mais pour arroser pour
faire marcher les moulins et puis aussi
pour transporter c'était aussi pour
permettre la navigation alors il a fallu
attendre ensuite effectivement les
années 60 pour que tous ces équipements
soient construits développés un
serpention 59 mais vraiment la totalité
du canal c'est plutôt la deuxième partie
des années 60 aujourd'hui quelques
chiffres je vais pas vous vous assommer
le chiffre mais quand même quelques
chiffres cette chaîne de la Durance et
du Verdon ça assure l'eau potable pour 3
millions de personnes l'irrigation de à
peu près le chiffre qu'on donne nous
c'est 120 000 hectares de terres
agricoles c'est 440 entreprises qui sont
alimentées en eau industrielle et puis
et puis et bien c'est plus de 2
gigawatts installés et c'est que ça
correspond donc à une production
d'électricité pour plus de 2 millions de
personnes et puis il y a un usage
additionnel qui s'est ajouté qui était
pas forcément à identifier à l'origine
qui est toute l'offre touristique et
toute l'utilisation touristique qui est
faite du lac de Serre-Ponçon
Serre-Ponçon et 1,2 milliard de mètres
cubes de capacité de capacité de
stockage et c'est ce c'est justement le
lac de les bords du lac de Serre-Ponçon
qui a été choisi pour pour l'annonce du
plan O
c'est un exemple il y en a d'autres il y
en a un qui qui vous est cher monsieur
le rapporteur je sais avec le bassin à
bourg-garonne et les et les contrats de
coopération qui ont été signés en 2020
2022 dans lesquels on reconnaît que
l'eau doit servir à autre chose aussi à
l'irrigation et pas seulement à la
production d'électricité peut-être
encore un chiffre puis j'arrêterai avec
les chiffres après je me promets mais
c'est aujourd'hui 70% de nos concessions
EDF qui qui font autre chose que
simplement de la production
d'électricité plus de 2/3 de nos
concessions font déjà pas seulement de
la protection d'électricité dont autant
dire que le multi-usage c'est vraiment
dans notre ADN et bien sûr que et bien
sûr que pour nous c'est c'est absolument
essentiel on ré abordera la question de
l'acceptabilité mais bien sûr on en a
conscience et puis encore une fois c'est
plus que on a conscience et on fait pour
l'acceptabilité c'est c'est aussi cette
gestion de l'eau elle est clé pour pour
le pays et pour tous ces usages
alors vous aviez vous y aborder le point
de est-ce que le changement climatique a
un impact sur la ressource en eau oui ce
serait ce serait idiot de vouloir le
nier il a un impact qu'on maîtrise bien
à travers l'augmentation des
températures qui va augmenter
l'évaporation l'évapo transpiration et
donc ça ça diminue la ressource en eau
qui oui allez-y interrompez-moi je
termine 3 minutes
et puis la baisse des précipitations ça
c'est ça c'est sans doute plus difficile
à capter mais oui nous notre estimation
c'est à peu près un terrain wattheure de
moins par par décennie sur nos ouvrages
donc par rapport à une production
annuelle à peu près de aujourd'hui de
40-44 terrawatt-
mais je voudrais quand même revenir sur
l'hydroélectricité pour nous c'est
l'outil idéal de lutte contre le
changement climatique par deux biais 1
ça permet de limiter notre impact sur le
changement climatique à double titre
d'ailleurs on pourrait presque dire que
c'est une énergie renouvelable au carré
puisque elle n'aimait pas de CO2 et elle
permet d'insérer plus de d'énergie
renouvelable intermittente donc c'est
vraiment un outil idéal pour limiter
notre impact et puis elle ne fait pas
que limiter notre impact sur le
changement climatique c'est aussi un
outil de résilience on le voit à travers
le multi-usage le stock le stockage
d'eau et d'électricité qu'on peut faire
et elle a un potentiel de développement
qui est qui est réel et qui existe mais
on y reviendra merci Madame berger
monsieur Cyril Delprat société
hydroélectrique du Midi
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame sénatrice monsieur
messieurs les sénateurs merci pour nous
donner ce champ d'expression sur ce
sujet donc en deux mots la chaîne
société hydroélectrique du Midi
troisième producteur français
d'hydroélectricité filiale du groupe
engie qu'il est lui-même le deuxième
producteur hydroélectricité français
donc c'est 56 barrages 56 usines pardon
12 barrages répartis sur le Grand
Sud-Ouest donc chaîne des Pyrénées et
Massif Central principalement des actifs
de haute et moyennes chute ça veut dire
lac est éclusé ça veut dire flexibilité
l'hydroélectricité première énergie
renouvelable mais stockage d'énergie
flexibilité complémentarité avec le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien donc un rôle
crucial aujourd'hui mais encore plus
demain
deuxième caractéristique pour la chaîne
au-delà de la production d'électricité à
l'image de ce qui a pu être dit par
Madame verger contribution à
alimentation en eau des territoires en
aval
niveau de la chaîne
on a cette activité là depuis des
décennies puisque on produit l'énergie
depuis presque 100 ans et
on le coupe avec avec aussi cette
fournitures d'électricité de dos en aval
le plateau gascon que vous connaissez
sur le bassin à Burgaronne étant une
impasse hydrique et a besoin d'être
alimentée ce à quoi nous contribuons et
pour l'illustrer le quelle quantité
d'eau nous fournissons dans les périodes
etiages pour aider les territoires le
volume de nos barrages et des retenus
associés quand on en fait la somme
si on met ça en rapport de l'eau que
nous fournissons en été c'est 60% de ses
volumes de de nos lacs que nous
fournissons en été donc nous sommes déjà
très présents sur ce sujet
l'hydroélectricien est au croisement de
ces deux enjeux majeurs aujourd'hui et
encore plus demain puisque le bassin
doit Garonne fait partie des zones en
tension et qui le sera sans doute parmi
les plus intentions encore demain donc
nous contribuons et nous devons
continuer à contribuer il y a des
questions qui doivent se poser sur les
arbitrages de ce multi-usage comment on
les fait l'année 2022 est un homme en
est un bon exemple avec des injonctions
contradictoires entre garder l'eau pour
produire l'hiver parce que risque de
coupure et puis fournir de l'eau l'été
puisque sécheresse extrême
des questions qui se poseront aussi
lorsque les prix de l'élecs vont
diminuer bien sûr sur le modèle
économique associé qui doit être
réfléchi avec nous acteurs
hydroélectricien pour ça il y a une
condition à réunir c'est il faut de la
visibilité sur ce sujet de devenir des
concessions et d’électriques et de
l'électrique qui durent depuis bien
longtemps
on a eu un pas de fait avec la loi sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables et on vous en remercie qui
permet de maintenant pouvoir investir
avec plus de facilité donc c'est très
positif mais on est encore dans cette
situation et il faut encore avancer et
avec un étant donné qu'on est le petit
acteur de des trois acteurs on a le
souhait d'être toujours là puisqu'on est
là depuis longtemps et qu'on a la
prétention de faire assumer notre
mission le faire avec équité aussi
également bien sûr
merci vous avez bien respecté vos temps
de parole j'ai laissé la parole
maintenant à Madame Laurence Boris
Bancel la Compagnie nationale du Rhône
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la signatrice
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis ravie d'avoir été conviée à
cette table ronde sur un sujet qui nous
mobilise et qui est au cœur de nos
préoccupations la gestion durable de
l'eau et ses enjeux au regard du
réchauffement climatique et évidemment
nous partageons l'idée d'agir ensemble
de manière concertée pour préserver les
usages et l'environnement donc c'est
c'est pour moi l'occasion de parler de
CNR et d'expliquer ce qu'est CNR et de
faire partager notre modèle et nos
ambitions pour la gestion globale du
fleuve Rhône puisque la Compagnie
nationale du Rhône on lui a confié la
gestion du Rhône et on nous l'a confié
il y a près de 90 ans et cette gestion a
été confirmée l'année dernière pour
années de plus grâce à la loi
aménagement du Rhône qui a été
promulguée le 28 février dernier donc
qu'est-ce que CNR je pense que c'est
important de le dire c'est d'abord le
premier producteur français à 100%
renouvelable à vainqueur au vent soleil
on représente avec un seul fleuve 25% de
l'hydro française de l'hydro au fil de
l'eau avec ses spécificités j'y
reviendrai nos missions donc aucun
fleuve au monde en fait ne dispose d'un
mode de gestion comparable à celui de
CNR puisque nous devons garantir la
gestion optimale de la ressource en eau
de manière holistique c'est à dire qu'on
a trois missions qui sont dévolues par
la loi la production d'hydroélectricité
la navigation et l'irrigation des terres
agricoles et ces trois missions sont
indissociables notre actionnariat est
également spécifique puisque les
territoires ont une place importante
dans notre taxe actionnariat les
territoires
représentent 17% de notre actionnariat
et dans la gouvernance ils ont leur
place comme la Caisse des dépôts des
consignations et notre actionnaire
industrielle engie
notre modèle industriel est aussi
spécifique puisque c'est un modèle
industriel et redistributif et nous
avons notamment une redevance sur
l'électricité produite qui est
proportionnelle au prix de l'électricité
captée autrement dit plus on capte de
l'électricité cher plus la revente est
élevée avec un seuil de 80% pour la
partie de l'électricité dont le prix est
supérieur à 80 euros par mégawattheure
donc en quelques chiffres pour ne pas
dépasser le temps qui met un parti
qu'est-ce que c'est CNR donc producteur
au fil de l'eau c'est à dire que nous
nous turbinons l'eau qui nous est donnée
on ne la stocke pas Emmanuel en amont
stocke le l'eau pour nous d'insé
barrages mais la neige la neige dans les
dans les montagnes est aussi un moyen de
stockage et bien évidemment le lac Léman
en amont du Rhône donc nous avons 20
centrales hydroélectriques et 19
barrages au fil de l'eau qui produisent
13,6trawh comme je l'ai dit environ 25%
de l'hydro française mais CN r c'est
aussi 330 km de voie navigable avec 14
écluses ce sont 17 sites industriels
portuaires le long du Rhône c'est 1400
emplois salariés et 14000 emplois
indirects
nous enjeux s'inscrivent dans l'objectif
national de transition énergétique et
écologique et d'indépendance énergétique
de la France d'abord accélérer le
développement de nos actifs
renouvelables et dans le cadre de la
prolongation de la concession on y
reviendra on y reviendra pardon nous
avons 500 millions d'euros de travaux à
réaliser et notamment un vingtième
ouvrage sur le Rhône un amont de la
confluence avec l'un que nous devons
étudier et autour duquel il y aura une
concertation la question de
l'acceptabilité que vous évoquiez sera
clé continuer à développer de l'éolienne
de photos les
usages du Rhône il faut que je m'arrête
je le détaillerai tout à l'heure
maintenir le lien de confiance avec les
territoires parce qu'ils sont vraiment
clés dans notre concession et également
être un acteur de l'innovation
suffisamment pour faire un pas en avant
vers un mix plus soutenable il y a
environ 2300 petites installations sur
les cours d'eau de nos territoires et la
qualité de ces installations
contemporaines est le fruit d'un
savoir-faire industriel français ancien
leur durabilité centenaire grâce à des
opérations de maintenance et de
modernisation régulière en font un don
pour les générations futures aujourd'hui
la production d'électricité alimente
l'équivalent de 27 millions de Français
et pourrait en alimenter 1,8 millions
supplémentaires d'ici 2028 si on nous
permet d'atteindre nos objectifs mode de
production le plus décarboné il est
aussi l'un des plus efficaces avec un
rendement énergétique avoisinant les
90%. une électricité qui participe à
l'autonomie énergétique des territoires
puisque la majorité de la production
alimente les collectivités avoisinantes
par ailleurs nous savons les enjeux
géopolitiques qui existent autour des
métaux rares dont notre mode de
production ne nécessite aucune
importation pas de pollution une énergie
décarbonée de nombreux sondages ont
montré quelle est l'énergie préférée des
Français
conscient de l'importance du cadre
réglementaire pour que nos activités
aient le moins d'impact sur les
écosystèmes nos installations sont
depuis quelques décennies les plus
conformes à toutes les exigences de la
loi notamment pour assurer la continuité
écologique qu'il s'agisse des passes à
poissons ou d'une meilleure gestion
collective des usages en bonne entente
avec toutes les parties prenantes du
cours d'eau nous adhérents s'attache à
ce que nos installations contribuent à
la biodiversité et contrairement à ce
que peuvent penser certaines
associations minoritaires elles n'ont
pas le monopole de l'amour de la faune
et de la flore qui peuple nos rivière
seulement nous sommes conscients de la
gravité des faits qui nous réunissent
pour cette mission concernant la gestion
durable de l'eau si nous sommes bien
entendu inquiets quant à l'impact sur la
production d'électricité due à la
diminution des débits nous sommes
peut-être encore plus inquiets de la
perturbation du cycle de l'eau et de ses
effets car oui nous sommes les premiers
à le constater le dérèglement climatique
des traques nos rivières et si certaines
de nos installations ont déjà eu leur
lot de cru et de sécheresse ce qui
n'était qu'une exception devient la
règle c'est pour cela que nous devons
user de tous les moyens à notre
disposition pour nous adapter à cette
réalité nous installations sont
majoritairement des ouvrages au fil de
l'eau ce qui les rend particulièrement
tributaires du régime hydrologique de la
rivière sur laquelle elle se trouve
pourtant même si les capacités de
stockage des retenus de nos petites
centrales sont minimes leur intérêt est
plus que crucial pour certaines
collectivités qui à l'image de l'été
passé ont pu en profiter ainsi nos
centrales sont autant de sentinelles qui
participent à réduire les impacts de la
sécheresse en assurant une disponibilité
limitée mais essentielle de l'eau
seulement si nous avons aujourd'hui à
notre disposition les moyens techniques
et politiques pour concilier ces deux
usages de production d'énergie et de
stockage de l'eau nous devons créer une
nouvelle politique de l'eau une
politique qui répartie équitablement
l'accès aux trois piliers de nos usages
l'eau potable l'eau comme bien de
consommation pour nos industries et
notre agriculture et l'eau comme moyen
de production d'électricité une
politique qui mettrait donc autour de la
table toutes les parties prenantes et
s'appuierait sur une vision globale de
sobriété et d'intelligence dans les
usages ainsi que sur une connaissance
fine de nos cours d'eau les experts
existent et nous pouvons faire preuve de
bon sens pour éviter que dans un avenir
proche les conflits de l'eau ne soient
monnaie courante il est donc nécessaire
de réfléchir à de nouvelles méthodes de
concertation pour éviter que certaines
décisions conséquences lourdes sur notre
production et sur la préservation de
cette ressource ne soit prise en
témoigne les décisions de
l'administration pour rehausser les
débits réservés sans démontrer l'intérêt
pour la biodiversité mais qui génère un
manque à gagner énergétique important
ainsi le risque serait pour notre
activité que des choix arbitraires basés
sur des idées reçues continuent à
déstabiliser une activité dont les
avantages pour la société sont
indéniables
merci Monsieur Davy donc la Fédération
des moulins de France Monsieur ekem oui
je présenterai peut-être la Fédération
très rapidement et ensuite monsieur
André pourra préciser des choses au
niveau de l'électricité donc simplement
pour dire trois minutes oui mais ça sera
moins simplement pour dire que nous
fédéons ensemble de d'associations
nationales départementales régionales et
locales et que actuellement nous
constatons que les moulins sont au cœur
de trois problématiques la province
problématique patrimoniale la
problématique environnementale et à
nouveau maintenant la problématique de
production à partir de l'énergie
hydraulique et là nous sommes sur la la
possibilité de production
hydroélectrique puisque de plus en plus
de personnes nous sollicitent pour avoir
le projet de production et je laisse la
parole à me suivre
au niveau des données sur
l'hydroélectricité les moulins
représentent peu de production n'allons
pas comparer à nos voisins j'insiste
toutefois c'est quand même le nombre
important de Moulins un activité
plusieurs dizaines de milliers et
quelques-uns commencent à produire
l'électricité depuis d'ailleurs
plusieurs décennies même mais les
moulins c'était avant l'électricité je
crois qu'il est bon toujours de le dire
un moulin en lui-même c'est quelques
dizaines de kilomètres ça va faire
sourire mes collègues à côté mais c'est
le nombre qui est là
le changement climatique nous le
subissons comme tout le monde et nous
commençons réellement à le subir et nous
avons peu comment dirais-je l'impact
dessus
le débit réservé vous nous avez parlé
des obligations
on respecte simplement lors des tiages
en se permet de dire attention à ce
débit réservé qui réserve tout au lit
mineur les biefs qui sont également
alimentés doivent aussi être maintenus
en eau pour un souci de
sauvegarde de la biodiversité qui existe
dans ses biefs c'est une affaire de
réglementation même sans produire
d'électro de l'électricité il faut quand
même maintenir cette vie
enfin je croise que nous voulons surtout
insister et ici c'est important c'est le
potentiel et le gisement hydroélectrique
pour les moulins alors on estime que une
vingtaine de milliers de Moulins
existants pourrait être équipés et
produire de l'électricité toujours avec
quelques dizaines de kilowatts
potentiel qui est alors c'est peu mais
ce n'est quand même non négligeable on a
parlé lorsque la loi accélération des
énergies renouvelables était en
discussion la fourchette basse était
estimée ce que j'ai retenu des échanges
qui ont eu lieu à 300 mégawatts c'est
quand même le tiers d'un réacteur
nucléaire facilement disponible je
voudrais insister là-dessus il génie
civil est là il suffit d'équiper ces
moulins s'ils veulent bien si on leur
permet de fonctionner
l'acceptabilité sociale est très forte
il existe un capital de sympathie à
l'égard des moulins des fois nous en
abusons même mais je crois qu'il faut le
dire et le localement alors je vais
prendre ma casquette de petit élu local
je suis maire de ma commune également je
dirais simplement mais comment peut-on
promouvoir les énergies renouvelables
dans leur ensemble comme l'éolien et le
photovoltaïque si dans le même temps on
entrave l'utilisation de l'énergie
hydraulique notamment sur les sites
existants et notre cas je vous assure
que moi sur ma petite rivière il y a
encore des moulins qui pourraient être
équipés et ça passerait très facilement
les gens sont tout à fait d'accord
l'absence de concurrence l'absence de
mise en concurrence pour les concessions
électriques les moulins sont peu
concernés on n'est pas sur le régime
d'un concession si on fait un parallèle
quand même la distinction est peut-être
à faire entre le comment dirais-je la
concession l'usage d'une chute et la
propriété intentionnaire qui est annexée
parce que quand même celui qui équipe un
ouvrage est obligé de faire
l'acquisition du foncier autour je sais
pas si nos voisins résonnent comme nous
mais ils ne remettent pas tout en cause
c'est peut-être une femme pour nous ce
serait une piste
quand une nuit
les moulins ne modifient pas le débit
d'un cours d'eau il ne prélève pas d'eau
et se content de la faire travailler
donc déjà
alors rétablissement de la continuité
écologique pour permettre à libre
circulation des poissons migrateurs
transfert des sédiments bon en général
les moulins représentent des ouvrages
qui sont peu impactants c'est des
hauteurs de chutes inférieures à 2
mètres
les poissons migrateurs ne sont pas
spécialement quand même gênés par les
moulins et faut arrêter avec ça les
anguilles remontés et ses pages moulins
existaient déjà depuis longtemps
oui mais enfin bon
transfert des sédiments
si le sédiments n'étaient pas circuler
par de l'amant vers Laval il y a
longtemps que les moulins seraient
totalement en sablés ça se fait
naturellement à travers une roue voire
une turbine et on a des organes de
décharge permettant de le faire
serpention tout à l'heure madame berger
il faisait allusion il est prévu que
dans je connais quand même un peu la
région j'y étais il y a 5 dans 5 600 ans
il sera comblé non ils exigent depuis 5
600 ans et ils sont toujours en état de
fonctionnement voilà bien merci de vous
pour liminaires donc je vais aller
laisser la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur Hervé gilet pour quelques
questions et puis ensuite vous répondrez
aussi de façon succincte pour éviter un
débat interactif parce que mes collègues
ont également des questions à vous poser
très bien merci monsieur le Président je
vous propose d'aborder trois batteries
enfin trois questions et puis on
reprendra si ça vous dérange pas l'ordre
un petit peu de de présentation alors
bien sûr ce qu'on souhaite mesurer
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment l'impact du
changement climatique sur les
prospectives que vous pouvez faire en
termes à la fois de débit et Diderot
électricité mais derrière cette question
il y a aussi la question de l'adaptation
aussi de vos installations nous
aimerions aussi avoir un retour par
rapport à ça et puisque on parle aussi
de l'adaptation et de l'optimisation
derrière l'optimisation aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez des scénarios
d'amélioration
à la fois de la ressource du stockage
éventuel est-ce qu'il y a des roses
possibles est-ce que l'amélioration des
matériels permettrait aujourd'hui
d'envisager des process qui soient
encore plus à la fois vertueux mais
surtout qui permettent de rendre des
usages encore plus intéressant que ceux
que vous avez pu décrire aujourd'hui sur
le soutien des tirages qui a un sujet
que nous avons pu travailler avec avec
certains sur le soutien des stages et
les débits réservés ce qui nous
intéresse aussi d'avoir votre regard sur
le règlement les évolutions
réglementaires éventuellement que nous
pourrions travailler des réservés des e
il y a aujourd'hui un des débats sur
effectivement
ces sujets là je peux témoigner d'un
travail de qualité je tiens à le
souligner qui a pu être fait notamment
sur sur le bassin d'urgaronne et qui
montre que la discussion la négociation
et l'implication de l'ensemble des
acteurs sur des positions de
responsabilité nous permettent de
trouver des chemins qui sont
effectivement intéressants mais
j'aimerais bien aussi avoir votre regard
et votre éclairage par rapport à ça et
donc revenir effectivement sur ces
scénarios
prospectifs et nous donner donc ces
éléments peut-être de vision pouvait
avoir sur les potentiels mais en
couplage bien sûr avec les besoins que
vous avez à gérer notamment sur les
soutiens des tirages je vous en prie
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de cette
question alors effectivement on vous a
dit que je reviendrai sur le potentiel
de développement
pour nous d'ailleurs maintenant c'est
des alors ça suppose de régler mais on y
reviendra peut-être après le sujet des
sujets des concessions mais on a un
accord donc on a donc je fais
l'hypothèse que c'est que ça puisse être
réglé rapidement effectivement nous
avons un potentiel
correctement
on va dire à la fois indiqué dans les
obligations etc c'est très clair juste
sur le potentiel de développement donc
on distingue nous des un potentiel
d'augmentation de puissance sur nos
installations existantes soit par des
machines plus efficaces soit parce que à
certains endroits on avait même en fait
déjà prévu au moment des constructions
de certaines usines la possibilité de
rajouter un groupe de production et donc
ce potentiel de développement
aujourd'hui nous on évalue à peu près
500 mégawatts
d'ici 2030 2035 on ajoute à ce potentiel
de développement 1,5 gigawatts donc 1500
MW de STEP donc c'est station de
transfert d'électricité par pompage et
puis vous l'avez mentionné oui nous
avons aussi des possibilités bien sûr de
réhausse de barrage donc là pas
nécessairement une augmentation de
puissance mais en revanche une
augmentation de quantité d'eau stockée
donc de quantité d'électricité
potentiellement stocker d'accord donc là
si on est plutôt sur de
l'augmentation d'énergie c'est à dire la
quantité d'électricité qu'on peut
produire en global sur l'année plutôt
qu'une augmentation à l'instant T de la
puissance
voilà mais il y a bien ces trois
potentiels de développement qui sont qui
sont importants j'ai parlé du potentiel
à horizon 2035 et ensuite on a encore à
peu près l'équivalent sur sur la
décennie qui suit vous évoquez les
rehausses vous pouvez nous les préciser
aujourd'hui
donc dans les dans les
dans les potentiels de réhaus ce qu'on
étudie sont plutôt effectivement ce qui
en ce qui nous concerne dans la dans la
partie sud-ouest
mais on peut en étudier on peut en
étudier d'autres
sur cette partie sur cette partie là
Monsieur Cyril Delprat
[Musique]
en termes de d'adaptation des
installations
comme je viens de le dire moins d'eau
moins de neige pour ce qui nous concerne
notre à notre échelle
on étudie ce sujet de réhausse de
barrage mais aujourd'hui on le voit
plutôt à la marge pourquoi parce que
comme je viens de le dire moins d'eau
moins d'eau à stocker et donc exactement
c'est
voilà il faut en avoir le besoin et
aujourd'hui il est plutôt à la marge sur
les installations qui nous concernent
pour les raisons que je viens
d'expliquer après en matière de
développement effectivement c'était
potentiel toujours à la marge de notre
taille
on a parlé de petit hydro Jean-Marc Lévy
on a parlé
c'est à considérer évidemment aussi
quand on aura des efforts à faire encore
plus fort sur la partie étiage il faut
qu'on puisse compenser avec de l'énergie
donc c'est important de pouvoir
développer
ce que je voulais souligner c'était à la
maille du bassin de Garonne comme le
indiqué il y a un travail déjà de
qualité qui a été fait qui projette qu'à
horizon 2050 sur un déficit hydrique de
l'ordre de un virgule 2 1,4 milliards de
mètres cubes d'eau ce qui est
considérable
le travail qui a été fait
embarquant les hydroélectricien donc EDF
bien sûr et la chaîne montre qu'on
pourrait avoir une contribution
supplémentaire de l'ordre de 150 à 200
millions de mètres crypto ce qui est
beaucoup ce qui est énorme mais on voit
qu'il en manque beaucoup donc
voilà il faut que les efforts soient
évidemment répartis et entre tous les
acteurs et c'est incontournable on en
sera d'entre eux
mais on voilà les proportions qui qui
sont projetées la maille du bassin
d'orgaronne donc vous parliez de de tout
à l'heure ça fait partie des choses
qu'il faut questionner aussi même si
c'est difficile bien sûr parce que
l'équation est difficile
vous permettez sur ce sujet là mais on
pourra aussi rebondir on voit que plus
on affine les modèles meilleur et bien
sûr le pilotage et donc ça c'est une
question qui est aussi sur la table ça
veut dire une meilleure connaissance
comme je l'indiqué précédemment au
travers à la fois d'indicateurs mais à
la fois au travers d’études aussi plus à
plus fondie on a vu qu'avec le BRGM en
fait aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas
forcément d'ailleurs toutes les les
capacités en fait des nappes aujourd'hui
elles sont pas forcément toutes connues
mais c'est juste un exemple qui peut
être donné donc le fait d'améliorer
aussi le pilotage que ça soit sur la
ressource et la consommation est
absolument pour nous essentiel donc je
sais pas si vous partagez aussi ces
sujets là et donc tout le débat autour
du Do aussi de soutien des tirages et du
débit réservé justement
questionne aussi la connaissance que
l'on peut avoir et le fait de pouvoir
avoir un pilotage qui soit le plus fin
possible donc il y aura sans doute au
niveau du rapport des propositions qui
qui seront faites sur le sujet
monsieur Delprat très bien Madame madame
Laurence borimansel donc pour
accompagnation du Rhône
le premier point de l'impact sur le
changement climatique donc on peut dire
que déjà on observe c'est-à-dire ce
qu'on observe c'est des variations très
importantes de l'hydrolicité juste un
exemple l'année dernière donc la
sécheresse nous a impacté on a 3000
mégawatts installé sur le Rhône quand
tout va bien on produit l'équivalent de
2700 MW de puissance début septembre on
était capable de produire avec l'eau que
nous donnait le Rhône 230 230 2700 donc
concernant le l'impact du changement
climatique donc il y a une étude qui est
donc qui vient de sortir faite par
l'Agence de l'eau et qui qui est toute
récente et qui montre effectivement les
impacts du changement climatique sur le
Rhône à l'horizon 2055 ce que montre
cette étude c'est que en fait le débit
moyen du rôle ne semble pas évoluer
énormément par contre on aura vraiment
beaucoup d'eau en hiver et pas assez
d'eau en été si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
on voit que le débit desiages vont être
sont déjà impactés depuis depuis 1960
qui sont déjà impactés de moins 7 % à la
main jusqu'à moins de 13 % à Laval mais
que à l'horizon 2055 ce débit desiages
pourra être impacté à nouveau de moins
20% à Laval par contre en hiver on aura
plus d'eau donc ça c'est c'est ce que ce
sont les conclusions de cette étude ce
que cette étude montre aussi c'est qu'il
y aura moins de précipitations solides
moins de neige donc déjà on observe que
depuis
1960 sur les massifs qui alimentent le
Rhône on a déjà moins 10% de
précipitations neigeuses et ce que dit
l'étude c'est qu'à l'horizon 2055 on
pourrait avoir de -20 à moins 40% de
neige ce qui veut dire que ce stock en
fait de do que qu'on avait en hiver de
manière naturelle on ne l'aura plus donc
l'impact l'impact climatique
il est là et en termes d'adaptation ça
veut aussi dire que notre dans notre
manière d'exploiter il faut qu'on soit
plus flexible de manière à être capable
de turbiner l'eau quand elle est là
puisqu'encore une fois les les le fil de
l'eau bah ils turbine l'eau que le
fleuve veut bien lui donner sur la
question du développement donc j'en ai
touché deux mots dans mon propos
introductif dans le cadre de de la
prolongation de notre concession nous
sommes tenus de faire un certain nombre
d'investissements sur le Rhône et donc
il est il est prévu outre le 20e
aménagement que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure qui est un aménagement qui qui
serait d'une puissance de 37 mégawatts
qui produirait 140 gigawh soit la
consommation d'une ville de de 70 000
habitants on a le projet également de
construire des petites centrales
hydrauliques donc sur 6 de nos
installations existantes alors nous
quand on dit petite centrale hydraulique
ça veut dire entre 5 et 10 MW donc ça
veut dire en gros 100 GW de production
en tout donc on a l'intention donc de
l'intention conformément à notre cahier
des charges de construire ces six petits
centralisoliques on a aussi le donc le
projet d'augmenter la capacité d'un de
nos aménagements donc c'est
l'aménagement de mon telemars où on va
où on va d'une part augmenter la hauteur
d'eau et d'autres parts
changer des turbines de manière à
augmenter la production et donc ce sont
des développements qui devraient nous
permettre de de produire donc 0,5
térawattheure de plus par an et
d'installer 100 mégawatts de puissance
en plus donc le Rhône va être on va dire
équipé de manière à délivrer davantage
de de d'électricité
merci Madame justement de passer la part
à Monsieur et la vie pour vous dire
aussi que une des réflexions aujourd'hui
c'est bien évidemment d'améliorer
si ce n'est le stockage mais la capacité
de pouvoir aussi développer des
stockages naturels bien sûr les eaux
humides et on voit bien que en fonction
de la proche climatique c'est
particulièrement pertinent
puisqu'effectivement dans beaucoup de
bassins on va avoir des pluviométries
plus importantes à certains moments et
plus faible effectivement à d'autres et
toutes les stratégies à ce niveau là
sont intéressantes pour voir comment on
peut améliorer le stockage voire même de
la réinfiltration au niveau des nappes
donc voilà c'est un sujet aussi que l'on
met sur la table Monsieur Lévy
effectivement donc le changement
climatique nous préoccupe grandement
mais mais si on est si on est vigilant
on est raisonnablement inquiet en fait
ne t'inquiétude elle porte davantage sur
le rythme du réchauffement climatique
qui semble s'accélérer donc
effectivement vous l'avez dit il y aura
plus d'eau à certains moments et à
certains endroits et donc plus de crus
et moins à d'autres et donc des étiages
plus forts et plus longs et Madame
boribansel elle l'a rappelé
on est assuré quand même d'une certaine
résilience de nos ouvrages la filière
peut s'adapter dans une certaine mesure
évidemment on peut dans certains cas
étant dans les plages de fonctionnement
par du sur équipement l'automatisation
il y a plein de solutions donc c'est une
adaptation certes relative mais qui
existe et je voudrais juste l'illustrer
on a j'ai regardé pour préparer cette
cette table ronde sur un parc de 30
centrales dans les Vosges sur les 20
dernières années il y a deux périodes de
10 ans donc 2002-2012 2022
et bien la baisse de production sur ce
parc là entre ces deux périodes et de
0,26%. donc non significative à ce stade
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que la
petite hydro c'est c'est vraiment de la
haute couture c'est tout est dimensionné
par rapport aux enjeux environnementaux
du site
et on l'a rappelé en introduction mais
avant d'arriver dans l'océan l'océan a
beaucoup d'usages dont la production
hydroélectrique et il faut vraiment
réfléchir en termes de parcours de l'eau
pour optimiser tous les usages
quand il n'y a quand il y a des seuils
l'eau stagne un peu et donc cela
s'infiltre davantage et ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que les retenus
sont des milieux écotomes c'est-à-dire
riches en biodiversité et des refuges
pour les poissons alors sur le débit
réservé
j'ai envie de vous dire il faut pas
gaspiller l'eau mais il faut pas
gaspiller les kilowatt-heure non plus
un débit réservé c'est une perte
systématique d'énergie renouvelable
parfois sanguin pour l'environnement et
c'est ça le problème il faut préserver
au maximum le productible et que les
débits réservés ne soient relevés que
lorsque c'est réellement indispensable
parce qu'on est tout à fait d'accord
pour les relevés lorsqu'il y a
effectivement des données scientifiques
qui montrent que le débit actuel n'est
pas suffisant mais il faut beaucoup de
vigilance sur cette question là et
aujourd'hui malheureusement de plus en
plus souvent les relèvement de débit
réservés sont assez systématique parce
que on est vu par la direction de l'eau
comme un obstacle à la continuité
écologique et sur ces questions là on
peut pas dire que la direction de
l'énergie nous soutiennent beaucoup en
termes de scénario prospectif et de
potentiels de développement je m'en
propose introductif était centré
là-dessus mais le potentiel de
développement il est de 12 terwatts 20%
en plus et en termes d'objectifs en
revanche de développement soutenable par
la filière on propose alors là ce sont
les chiffres filières donc travailler
avec nos collègues au sein de l'UFE et
au sein du Syndicat des énergies
renouvelables mais on propose donc plus
625 mégawatts à 2028 donc en nouveaux
ouvrages ça représente 300 mégawatts
c'est à peu près 240 en nouveaux
ouvrages et 60 en seuil existant en
équipement de sa existant l'augmentation
de puissance à l'occasion des
rénovations d'ouvrages pour 100
mégawatts et puis les augmentations de
puissantes de puissance pardon des
concessions à l'horizon 2028 le chiffre
est de 210 MW et puis plus 790 MW entre
2028 et 2033 mais on vous fera passer
tout ça
merci beaucoup monsieur et quand même et
Monsieur André donc pour terminer les
moulins ne prétendre ne peuvent
prétendre à faire du soutien des
Tillages soyons que ils sont tous au fil
de l'eau par contre je réitère ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure attention au
débit réservé je rejoins entièrement ce
que disait Jean-Marc Levy
protection de la biodiversité je parlais
des biefs existants sous prétexte de
maintenir un débit réservé faisons
attention quand même à laisser de l'eau
dans des BF existants nos petites
retenues également dans la mesure où
elle ont une riche biodiversité elles
alimentent les nappes phréatiques et
notamment les zones humides si vous
abaissez la retenue amont d'un ouvrage
qui a un amant automatiquement la
surface qui est
couverte par cette retenue va se
rétrécir et vous aurez une zone humide
qui sera inévitablement impacté c'est
pour ça qu'il faut être très vigilant
également là-dessus voilà le ce que l'on
peut dire nous pour je reprendrai après
le prospectif j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure bien merci beaucoup peut-être à
ce stade de la discussion on peut
demander à nos collègues s'ils ont des
points particuliers ou des questions à
poser à nos invités
juste une question Cyril pelvache
sénateur de la Haute-Savoie et nous
avons sur le territoire je pense
certains le savent un projet de
centrales enfin qui m'aime plus qu'un
projet puisqu'il a abouti donc il y a
Sallanches qui a été attaqué par France
Nature Environnement et pour le coup le
jeu administratif a donné raison on est
aujourd'hui dans une procédure on doit
annoncer le démontage donc c'est 6
millions d'euros d'investissement 10
millions d'euros pour la défaire et pour
le coup les raisons abordées sont la
biodiversité donc ma question est alors
on parlait tout à l'heure des diverses
préoccupations de l'acceptabilité autre
pensez-vous pas que s'il devait y avoir
une jurisprudence ben derrière ça mettra
en péril toutes les projets de
développement ou d'extension et deuxième
des choses si on devait avoir gain de
cause est-ce que derrière il y aurait
pas un moyen d'associer ou du moins quel
serait les préconisations qui pourraient
être émises pour en tout cas travailler
peut-être conjointement avec des
associations qui parfois ont une
mauvaise connaissance m'attaque tout par
volonté et peut-être des juges qui sont
peut-être complaisants et on le voit sur
de nombreux dossiers notamment d'autres
dossiers liés à l'eau comme retenu
colinéaire et j'en passe voilà
bonjour Daniel broyer sénateur du
Val-de-Marne juste une remarque avant de
poser ma question le sujet de
biodiversité est un véritable sujet donc
la question est vraiment celle des
arbitrages entre un ensemble de besoins
préservés les milieux et la ressource
fournir de l'énergie
pouvoir servir l'agriculture et puis
d'abord servir aussi évidemment la
consommation d'eau potable moi je
voulais savoir si vous aviez des
remarques sur les bonnes pratiques pour
soutenir l'acceptabilité c'est-à-dire si
vous avez les bons exemples des
structures qui permettent le dialogue
justement entre les associations de
défense de la nature les fournisseurs
d'électricité les agriculteurs et les
industriels enfin disons la diversité
des consommations des consommateurs dans
les collectivités territoriales
évidemment
moi j'ai juste une
oui merci beaucoup et merci pour tous
ces éléments un petit peu ma question
rejoignait celle de mon collègue en
effet sur les bonnes pratiques notamment
au moment de la concertation pour qu'on
n'arrive pas à ces situations postes et
d'efficacification de la structure avec
une décision qui sans doute été payée
n'est pas forcément
repose pas forcément sur des idées
reçues non mais faut voilà mais je pense
que le travail à Mont et va absolument
indispensable pour sécuriser davantage
les ouvrages et est-ce que voilà c'est
une perspective sur laquelle vous
travaillez
voilà améliorer la qualité de ce travail
à mon et peut-être une autre question
bon je connais un peu mieux la CNR
puisque c'est mon c'est mon territoire
en fait on voit bien en réalité que
l'hiver la production des droits
électricité ne posera pas problème et en
finalement la CNR a bien anticipé cela
puisque elle produit aussi d'autres ENR
notamment le solaire qui est amené à
compenser l'été donc est-ce que sur les
autres structures vous avez aussi cette
démarche là pour compenser avec d'autres
ENR l'été l'hydroélectricité forcément
qui est un peu plus faible sur cette
période
merci moi j'ai juste une question cela
l'accroissement de la hauteur des
barrages puisque il pleut plus l'hiver
est-ce qu'on a déjà une idée du
pourcentage de la hauteur qu'il faudrait
pour garantir la stockage plus important
ou pas ou si c'est simplement en
fonction des lieux et au petit bonhomme
de chemin et puis
merci je vous propose que vous répondiez
voilà
donc sur sa lance effectivement monsieur
sénateur si ça faisait jurisprudence
effectivement il faudrait attendre que
que les recours soient purgés pour
construire
ceci dit dans le dispositif de la loi
accélération des énergies renouvelables
il y a voilà il est prévu une espèce
d'assurance une fois l'autorisation
donnée pour construire et si
l'autorisation était retirée ou annulée
voilà l'assurance fonctionnerait sur les
sur les associations écoutez il y a pas
de contestation des citoyens sur notre
énergie ce qui est suffisamment rare
pour le souligner il y a une excellente
acceptabilité locale des citoyens des
élus c'est je vous l'ai dit l'énergie
préférée des Français la contestation
elle est le fait d'associations qui ont
fait des recours leur métier leur
gagne-pain en attaquant sans
discernement je l'assume les
autorisations et le problème c'est qu'il
y a on a un état qui ne défend pas
toujours ses autorisations ça ça pose
quand même problème si vous vous
permettez on connaît bien et vos propos
retrouve très bien défendre un point de
vue qui est très particulier le problème
qui est posé est posé par mes collègues
c'est ok c'est la réalité peut-être de
la situation que vous évoquez mais
comment on fait derrière ça c'est à dire
que quels sont les chemins pour aller
vers une forme d'acceptabilité il y a
aujourd'hui les ptge qui sont évidemment
questionnés sur leur intérêt les projets
territoire c'est ça le fond du sujet oui
argentin je termine juste le propos sur
sur l'état qui ne défend pas toujours
ses autorisations au tribunal soit dit
en passant ça n'encourage pas les
préfets à délivrer une nouvelle
autorisations et c'est un état qui
finance aussi ces associations
d'ailleurs il y a déjà des élus qui dans
le territoire qui qui ont supprimé
certaines subventions la concertation en
hydro elle est elle est très très large
elle est prévue par la loi elle est à
toutes les étapes et ça lance en été en
été une illustration enfin je veux dire
ils ont ils ont coché toutes les cases
il y a aucun projet qui se fait dans le
dos des associations nous ce qu'on
constate quand même puisque il s'agit de
France Nature Environnement en
l'occurrence sur leur site ou dans leur
discours me soutiennent toutes les
énergies renouvelables dans les faits
ils attaquent toutes nos autorisations
et je voudrais juste dire qu'en
hydroélectricité pour obtenir votre
autorisation ça prend entre deux et 7
ans c'est très très lourd il faut
vraiment montrer pas de blanche sur tous
les sujets et qu'elle puisse être mise
en côte en cause parce que on vous dit
que 400 kW c'est pas d'intérêt public
majeur vous le démontrez pas assez
voilà donc là on a pour répondre à votre
question on n'a pas encore la solution
on essaie de faire notre maximum pour le
concerter mais souvent d'ailleurs ces
associations ne sont pas autour de la
table et sortent du bois voilà le
dernier jour du délai de recours
vous n'êtes pas trop optimiste donc il
faut être plus dur juridiquement
d'autres remarques je vous en prie
peut-être
sur l'adaptation changement climatique
moi je pense que en ce qui concerne EDF
le fait qu'on ait un mix de production
diversifiée fait pas de doute bon
j'avais évoqué l'impact moi du
changement climatique dans mon propos
introductif mais peut-être quand même
oui est-ce que est-ce que ça nous amène
à nous adapter aussi dans notre gestion
de notre part hydroélectrique bien sûr
par exemple on a évoqué la baisse du
stock de neige il y a il y a la baisse
et le fait qu'elles font plutôt pour
nous c'est des gestions alors on a
évoqué je crois que c'est vous monsieur
gilet qui avait évoqué la nécessité
d'avoir une expertise pour piloter tout
ça au mieux un lac évidemment il faut en
fait qu'il arrive à la veille de la
fonte des neiges pas trop plein sinon il
va déborder quand la neige fond et c'est
pas non plus ce qu'on veut puisqu'on
veut pas avoir enfin je pense que
évidemment c'est c'est pas l'objet donc
oui ça nous amène ça nous a amené nous à
développer une expertise très pointue
sur cette sur ce changement climatique
pour en comprendre les effets c'est pas
toujours simple mais pour pouvoir
piloter au mieux affiner le pilotage de
nos ouvrages pour que ils permettent ils
permettent de de stocker l'eau au moment
où elle arrive derrière nos retenues et
pour au maximum de ce qu'on sait faire
avec nos barrages retenir le moment
finalement où elle va devenir salée
parce que c'est ça qu'on fait avec nos
barrages c'est qu'on la maintient douce
plus longtemps en fait et ça permet de
produire de l'électricité au meilleur
moment mais ça permet aussi de disposer
d'eau douce dans des quantités plus
raisonnables et plus acceptable enfin
meilleur plus importante au moment où on
en aura le plus besoin et pour répondre
à votre question monsieur le monsieur le
Président sur sur la hauteur de la
possibilité de réhausse de barrage c'est
du cas par cas ça m'a vraiment aide du
cas par cas parce que évidemment quand
on réhausse un barrage on va aussi
potentiellement augmenter la surface qui
va être immergée donc évidemment là on
va on va tomber sur des des questions de
en tout cas qui sont à regarder vraiment
au cas par cas en fonction des besoins
en aval en fonction des caractéristiques
de la zone dont on parle des questions
d'acceptabilité donc c'est donc c'est
vraiment du cas par cas peut-être pour
l'instant
alors nous on a des projets quand même
assez sérieux bon mais mais alors
peut-être juste sur l'acceptabilité
parce qu'il a été dit tout à l'heure par
sur l'acceptabilité puisqu'il a été dit
tout à l'heure que l'hydroélectricité
était très bien acceptée c'est vrai bon
nous pour nous on se fait pas non plus
trop d'illusions c'est à dire que c'est
aussi parce qu'on n'a pas fait de
développement majeur donc on n'a pas de
en tout cas on sous-estime pas le fait
que il y aura une opposition quand on
quand on sera quand on va trouver la
solution qui nous permettra de reprendre
ce développement dont on est vraiment
persuadé que le pays a besoin j'espère
que ça vous vous l'avez compris dans les
bonnes pratiques quand même
on est très ancré dans les territoires
on a et ne serait-ce que pour les
questions de gestion des tirages une
grande expertise dans la concertation
avec toutes les parties prenantes et
puis on a développé un programme qui
s'appelle une rivière un territoire et
qui met l'accent alors ça a été dit
aussi tout à l'heure dans les propos
intréductif mais l'hydroélectricité
c'est d'abord une énergie qui est
souveraine et nous dans nos projets de
développement ce qu'il faut bien voir
c'est que EDF hydro c'est 5200 salariés
mais c'est 30000 emplois indirects si on
reprend le développement ça sera même
plus et c'est 60% des dépenses
d'investissement qui seront le plus
possible au cas en tout cas françaises
mais le plus possible au calme et voilà
donc il y a aussi ce vecteur de
développement économique pour nos
territoires qui me paraît qui se raclée
dans l'acceptabilité et ce programme une
rivière d'un territoire il fait savoir
ça il aide aussi des des entreprises
locales à se développer et voilà c'est
peut-être une bonne pratique en tout cas
ça on essaye de de d'apporter autant que
possible au territoire dans lesquels on
souhaite se développer
je vais vraiment me faire l'écho de ce
que tu viens de dire Emmanuel parce que
je pense qu'effectivement
l'acceptabilité elle est pas gagnée donc
nous on va ce nouvel ouvrage que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure donc nouvelle
ouvrage sur le Rhône 20e ouvrage je
pense que même si l'hydroélectricité est
le nr préféré des français elle est pas
acquise et je suis complètement alignée
avec ce que disait Emmanuel sur le fait
que pour soutenir cette acceptabilité il
faut qu'il y ait un vrai bénéfice au
territoire et c'est parce que c'est
c'est parce que le projet est un projet
de territoire que on peut gagner et et
réussir à développer sur lesquels on
essaye aussi d'approfondir la réflexion
politique au sens noble du terme mais
j'y reviendrai voilà et donc
effectivement ce que ce que ce qui était
décrit par Emmanuel le une rivière en
territoire CNR c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment ça en fait le Rhône et ses
territoires enfin d'ailleurs on a une
raison d'être qui est le Rhône pour
originaire pour origine pardon les
territoires pour partenaires et les
renouvelables pour l'avenir
donc je vais pas redire pas mal de
choses comme j'ai été effectivement le
sujet de l'ancrage
historique
est un facteur aidant fortement dans le
dans les relations locales reste
[Musique]
je pense aussi que ça passe par là que
la créativité elle passe par là
c'est-à-dire montrer que que on est des
acteurs sérieux et que on veut pas faire
n'importe quoi et je pense que les
acteurs qui sont autour de la table sont
tous dans cette optique là quoi donc ça
c'est un premier point ensuite sur le
le la compensation de de la tension de
l'été oui on s'inscrit dans dans ce que
vous indiquez alors nous de notre côté
chef on ne fait pas de l'hydro de pardon
de PV et d'éolien on fait partie d'un
groupe qui qui a des filiales qui font
qui font ça un jigrid notamment qui est
qui est à la pointe sur ces sujets là et
qui complètent à la maille du groupe
enfin sur la partie barrage dont je
n'avais dit un mot tout à l'heure à
notre my de notre territoire en tout cas
sous le soleil sur lequel on nous
opérons c'est les sujets qu'on regarde
mais c'est plutôt à la marge aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas de déversement majeurs
qui justifieraient pour amortir les
crues plus fortement de d'aller plus
haut et tant entendu que
que le reste du temps on aura plutôt un
peu moins d'eau que l'on a aujourd'hui
et que donc il faut pouvoir justifier de
l'ensemble néanmoins ça permet de
souligner à travers ce que vous avez pu
indiquer le rôle aussi des barrages dans
la dans la gestion des crues
le rôle des barrages et de remettre en
perspective l'histoire et aujourd'hui
s'il n'était pas là nous aurions aussi
un certain nombre de difficultés donc ce
qui ramène aussi au fait d'avoir une
approche sociétale à un moment donné et
donc de prendre l'ensemble des
externalités pour pouvoir juger la de
l'impact et de la pertinence d'un projet
donc ça aussi ça fait partie du débat
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que une clé
d'entrée et toutes les externalités
aujourd'hui au niveau des projets sont
pas forcément
véritablement intégrés pour permettre
ensuite d'avoir une cristallisation de
décisionnelle qui soit la plus partagée
possible donc il y a aussi un sujet je
pense aussi mais c'est aussi une
interpellation à vous tous d'ailleurs
que en termes d'information et de
communication on a sans doute pas encore
aujourd'hui fait ce qu'il fallait faire
d'abord parce que la communication
institutionnelle est de plus en plus
décriée et donc il faut y regarder d'un
peu plus près ça veut dire si elle est
de plus en plus décriée comment s'adapte
derrière tout ça
et que si on veut politiser le sujet de
l'eau là aussi au sens noble du terme
les stratégies d'information de
communication de relations avec
l'ensemble des usagers sont de plus en
plus déterminantes tous les niveaux de
responsabilités sont évidemment
concernées mais vous aussi quelque part
et donc on voit bien que ces sujets sont
encore trop faibles ou du moins mérite
d'être questionné comme quand je parlais
de la communication institutionnelle
excusez moi à chaque fois qu'on nous
voit arriver avec un costard-cravate et
des documents qu'on est sur la table il
y a tout de suite un sentiment de
méfiance faut dire les choses comme
elles sont aujourd'hui mais c'est un
sujet qui est puissant c'est un sujet
qui est vraiment majeur aujourd'hui
et c'est pas un détail c'est pas un
détail
on va aborder le sujet qui est le sujet
sur l'évolution des concessions
aujourd'hui pour avoir aussi votre
regard parce qu'il est il est important
de rappeler que la Commission européenne
donc a mis en demeure même la France
donc sur le fait qu'on est très avantage
sur la mise en concurrence des
concessions hydroélectriques vous
connaissez les articles du traité qui
sont concernés sur ces sujets là donc
quels sont pour vous les solutions
juridiques politiques pour surmonter
justement ces difficultés nous y sommes
tous particulièrement sensible parce
qu'on voit bien les enjeux qu'il peut y
avoir derrière le fait de maîtriser
d'avoir une prospective qui soit la plus
assurée possible en fonction de
l'ensemble des usages est-ce que vous
avez des éléments particuliers peut-être
à nous communiquer sur ces sujets là
est-ce que vous avez des informations
peut-être à nous donner sur les
négociations qui sont en cours même si
là nous sommes dans le cadre d'un débat
public ouvert et qu'effectivement on
n'est pas
je vous en prie qui commence
je commence bon
en tout cas le message que je voudrais
passer moi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est que c'est absolument clé de de
trouver une solution qui permette de
reprendre le développement se
développements on a dit le potentiel il
existe il est réel
peut-être qu'on en avait pas besoin il y
a 10 ans aujourd'hui je pense que on a
vraiment besoin de se mettre en position
de pouvoir le développer et c'est
maintenant qu'on en a besoin je l'ai dit
ça permet d'insérer plus de NR ça permet
de produire plus d'électricité au bon
moment
[Musique]
évidemment de l'électricité sans
émission de CO2 et
ça permettra de faire de toute façon
nous on n'a pas un seul de nos projets
qui n'est pas conçu comme comme multi
avec un angle multi-usage de l'eau c'est
une évidence jamais on s'est senti de
propriétaire de l'eau donc ça pour nous
c'est une évidence
sur les solutions oui je vais pas
pouvoir en dire beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui on est en train de de
vraiment toutes les évaluer essayer de
trouver la plus adaptée mais ce que je
voudrais passer comme message c'est que
pour nous le statu quo c'est pas une
bonne option
ce n'est pas une bonne option ce n'est
pas aujourd'hui c'est bloquant pour la
mise en oeuvre du développement et du
potentiel de développement qui réel et
qui pourrait entrer en service dans les
dans les années dans la décennie qui
vient
et alors il faudrait la dire quoi
non mais voilà je vais pas pouvoir en
dire plus sur les solutions ou la
solution là où les solutions qui nous
paraissent les plus adaptées évidemment
ce qu'on cherche c'est des solutions qui
permettent de d'éviter les mises en
concurrence et de maintenir les
concessions dans les entreprises qui ça
a été dit je crois enfin je crois
qu'elles sont bien gérées aujourd'hui
puissent continuer à être développés et
bien géré par les entreprises qui gèrent
aujourd'hui
à ce stade c'est se traduit bien
moi je me prononcerai pas sur sur la
situation donc de des mises en demeure
mais je voudrais simplement dire que CNR
a été prolongé donc comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure par une loi le 28 février
dernier qu'effectivement ça nous permet
de lancer un programme de travaux de
développement et de lancer des travaux
de renouvellement d'équipement etc donc
voilà c'est la seule chose que je dirais
juste pour notre gouverne parce que là
c'est une forme d'approche juridique
particulière que vous concernant mais
parce qu'il y avait qu'est-ce qu'il a
justifié en tant que tel parce qu'il y a
pas eu de mise en concurrence en tout
cas c'est une loi qui a prolon déjà la
concession du Rhône c'était une loi
c'était une loi qui datait de 1921 donc
effectivement la prolongation d'une loi
qui s'appelait aménagement du Rhône et
là prolongation elle a été elle aussi
donc portée par un projet de loi et donc
elle a fait l'objet d'une loi donc oui
c'était un cas particulier
l'Europe a évidemment été dans la boucle
et donc à accepter cette prolongation
oui mais il me semble que c'est aussi eu
égard aux multiples activités de la CNR
et pas seulement à la production
hydroélectrique voilà cette loi a pu
être prise la loi s'appelle aménagement
du Rhône et comme je le disais merci
madame la sénatrice les missions de de
CNR c'est pas que de la production
d'électricité mais c'est bien la
production d'électricité la navigation
et l'irrigation des terres agricoles on
a vraiment cette triple mission et cette
gestion holistique du Rhône donc en
effet la concession du Rhône qui est
d'ailleurs concession du Rhône de la
frontière Suisse jusqu'à la Méditerranée
avec un aménagement EDF sur la route
parce que ça concession date de 1898
donc c'est c'est aussi une spécificité
spécificité de gestion holistique d'un
fleuve y compris dans toute sa
géographie
c'est pour ça qu'il faut donner des
identités au fleuve
vaste sujet
mais bon c'est intéressant de voir
comment ces sujets-là aussi peuvent
s'incarner avec des démarches
on va dire d'engagement et social qui
sont particulières et culturels
d'ailleurs
la loi qui existe transition énergétique
pour la croissance verte de 2015 ne
permet pas de trouver de réponse
satisfaisante à l'échelle de ce que l'on
vise il y a quatre possibilités
l'ouverture à la concurrence comme cela
a été dit par Emmanuel berger c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on souhaite aujourd'hui
le
créer des sociétés économistes hydro on
retombe sur un sujet d'ouverture à la
concurrence derrière et c'est très
compliqué ensuite prolongation pour
travaux l'Europe la rejeté en fait il
reste derrière barycentre qui est de
rassembler des concessions
hydrauliquement liées il faut des cas de
figures bien précis nous avions un chef
avec l'État prix un barycentre pour deux
ouvrages qui qui se regardent de chaque
côté de la Dordogne donc c'était le cas
d'école
il a été attaqué et était annulé pour
une raison en fait
juridique c'est à dire que la loi qui
décrivait le processus de Barry centre
et sont décret d'application ne disait
pas exactement la même chose donc sur le
fond il n'y avait pas de problème sur
les hypothèses prises il y avait pas de
problème mais il y avait besoin de
mettre en conformité la loi et le décret
donc travaux en cours mais ces
situations de barycentre voilà qui est
une possibilité elle reste très très
ponctuelle et répond pas au sujet dans
son ensemble donc du coup voilà les
travaux on cherche et depuis assez
longtemps puisque le sujet là depuis
2010 donc il y a pas de réponse évidente
immédiate sinon ça ferait un petit
moment je pense que que nos acteurs
aurait utilisé effectivement si je
prends une image un peu un peu
discutable
l'hydro publicité et le SAMU du réseau
électrique
l'année 2022 l'a illustré il n'y a pas
de demande d'acteurs équivalents pour ça
si on se projette dans un dans un schéma
de de maîtrise de nos émissions de
carbone donc on a besoin d'être là il y
a le sujet de l'eau qui est majeur et
auquel on est au cœur de ça également
peut-être y a-t-il des choses à
rechercher autour de ces deux sujets
mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas le en tout
cas la maille de la chaîne on n'a pas la
réponse définitive
pour l'instant
juste pour préciser voilà donc dit
autrement d'un point de vue juridique
c'est très compliqué il y a besoin d'une
imposition politique assez forte quoi
juste un point peut-être moins moins
connu enfin nous on est moins concerné
même si on a quelques concessions
puisque je vous rappelle que le seuil de
concession est à 4,5 mégawatts et que la
petite hydro ont la situe en dessous de
10 12 MW non ce que je voulais juste
dire c'est qu'on a besoin de visibilité
pour investir ça a été dit mais aussi
pour faire avancer des sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le renouvellement des
concessions mais qui sont paralysées de
ce fait et je prends l'exemple du
contrat rénovation entre 1 mégawatt et
4,5 MW donc sous autorisation ça n'a
rien à voir avec le sujet des
concessions mais la direction d'énergie
ne négocie pas ne souhaite pas négocier
aujourd'hui des dérogations en fait aux
appels d'offres parce qu'en fait au
dessus d'un Megawatt il faut passer par
appel d'offres or il faut rénover le
parc un appel d'offres pour la
rénovation ça n'a aucun sens puisque
l'idée de la rénovation c'est de
justement permettre à toutes les
centrales d'être modernisés et à compter
sur le parc existant donc si vous faites
un appel d'oeuvre c'est pour un écarter
certaines donc certaines ne pourront pas
se rénover donc voilà et donc
aujourd'hui ça fait depuis 2018 donc ça
fait cinq ans qu'on attend un contrat
rénovation pour les sous autorisation
pour les puissances de 1 à 4,5 MW mais
il a déjà qui ne peut pas aller voir la
Commission européenne en négociant une
dérogation aux appels d'offres au dessus
d'un Mégawat parce que le sujet des
concessions fait que ça les paralyse ça
les tétanise et ça n'avance pas voilà
c'est juste un effet collatéral de ce
sujet
je vous propose peut-être pour terminer
aller vers la conclusion mais vous avez
peut-être des sujets aussi particuliers
vous voulez de mettre en exergue revenir
sur la gouvernance la gouvernance
territoriale et puis aussi
la question de la gestion de crise
aujourd'hui que nous essayons aussi de
questionner d'une part est-ce que vous
estimez que les les procédures et les
méthodes de gestion de crise aujourd'hui
sont adaptées
on a le sentiment qu'elles sont tombées
dans une forme de routine pour tout dire
qu'elles ont du mal aujourd'hui à
s'adapter à des nouvelles réalités
en termes à la fois d'usage mais aussi
parfois
sur ne serait-ce que par exemple
l'arrosage en milieu urbain sur des
arbres qui sont plantés de plus de 5 ans
peut être interdits ou si juste des
exemples ce qui est une aberration toi
qu'un arbre il est planté il vaut mieux
l'arroser parce que le capital que vous
avez pu mettre
il faut quand même voilà le protéger
mais c'est juste un exemple pour
illustrer mais la notion de gestion de
crise peut être interrogée aujourd'hui
mais derrière ça il y a aussi la
gouvernance quel est votre regard
aujourd'hui sur la gouvernance qui
existe dans notre pays à l'échelle des
comités de de bassin sur les cellules de
crise et le rapport entre les différents
niveaux et les services de l'État
non mais sur la gouvernance
elle est quand même compliquée c'est un
investissement quand même pour pour la
comprendre en même temps voilà donc
après est-ce qu'elles fonctionnent en
tout cas oui pour nous elle fonctionne
elle permet quand même une bonne
implication une bonne concert un niveau
de concertation et d'implication de
consultation de toutes les parties
prenantes voilà avec et ça je trouve que
l'été dernier en tout cas nous c'est
notre retour sur l'été dernier on a eu
des endroits avec des arbitrages à faire
et des préfets qui ont joué leur rôle et
comme c'était bien après une phase de
consultation oui notre retour c'était un
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas du
retour d'expérience à faire il y a eu de
la consultation qui a pu se faire même
nous par exemple on prévoit des
échéances des jalons de consultation un
peu plus tôt que ce qui était prévu
cette année si l'année se révèle c'est
pas forcément c'est encore un peu tôt
pour le dire mais si on s'orient encore
vers une année de déficity hydrique et
bien on a prévu des jalons de
consultation ou d'informations pour être
plus transparent sur les données exactes
là si tu pour essayer de faire prendre
conscience à chacun de la situation
réelle de du cours d'eau qui le concerne
donc je pense que cette gouvernance est
elle est compliquée elle est je trouve
c'est pas toujours hyper lisible mais
elle fonctionne et elle permet une bonne
une bonne concertation nous semble-t-il
d'anticipation ce que je dis c'est que
nous effectivement cette année
c'est un des retours d'expérience de
l'année dernière je pense qu'en tout cas
des points de passage peut-être un peu
plus tôt que ce n'était fait jusqu'à
présent sur une information pour tout le
monde soit au même niveau d'information
en toute transparence sur la situation
de de la vallée ou du cours d'eau peut
être utile et c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce
qu'on a mis en place sur j'ai en tête le
j'étais dans le Jura la semaine dernière
voilà on sait des endroits où on a prévu
de faire ça
sur la gestion de crise
je savais pas forcément d'éléments
particuliers
merci c'est vrai qu'il y a des arrêtés
sécheresses qui sont assez différenciés
même entre deux départements
on s'est enfin en même temps c'est très
local c'est des réalités qui peuvent
être très différentes des problématiques
qui sont vraiment pas les mêmes donc que
ça ne puisse être fait ensuite kamaï
local nous semble nous normal
j'ai pas grand chose à rajouter notre
sentiment c'est qu'effectivement la
gouvernance fonctionne plutôt bien
peut-être un échange de bonnes pratiques
dans le cadre de notre concession on a
de ce qu'on appelle des comités de suivi
de la concession dans lequel il y a des
représentants des territoires dans de
l'État et des de ses services des
représentants d'association voilà sur
les grosses concessions chez chez ma
voisine aussi et donc ça permet de de
quelque part d'échanger
dans un format connu sur le l'actualité
et la de la concession donc et sur la
gestion de crise j'ai pas non plus alors
on est au fil de l'eau non donc en
turbine l'eau que l'on veut bien nous
donner et on le la stocke pas donc
peut-être que de ce fait on est on est
on est moins concerné quand il s'agit de
sécheresse on se coordonne de manière
efficiente avec les
centrales nucléaires qui sont sur le
Rhône de manière à les refroidir donc je
pas grand chose à rajouter de plus
de température en fait c'est à dire que
dans la mesure où le l'eau l'été dernier
voilà l'eau était chaude forcément avec
un delta t de 7 degrés en sortie il
était plus chaude
donc effectivement ce sentiment que
qu'on travaille bien avec l'ensemble des
acteurs
tout à l'heure je parlais de concessions
beaucoup d'échanges avec les services de
l'État souligner aussi au passage
le système est livré compliqué
il faut un peu de temps pour le digérer
pour autant il fonctionne dans son
ensemble néanmoins
j'utiliserai comme l'année 2022 qui est
peut-être représentatif de certaines
années qu'on aura plus tard
[Musique]
les arbitrages entre besoins des lECs et
d'électricité et besoin d'eau sont
passifs et immédiats
là on avait en 2022 des injonctions
contradictoires d'un côté
ministère qui nous disait préparez-vous
optimiser pour cet hiver puisque risque
de coupure
nous optimiser ça veut dire pas utiliser
l'eau l'été ou pas l'utiliser en
septembre en octobre en novembre voilà
et de l'autre côté bah situation de
tension sur le sur le sur le sur le
territoire avec de la sécheresse forte
ou d'un côté on nous disait il faut que
vous donniez de l'eau et voilà donc bien
sûr c'est pas nous d'arbitrer et là
c'est pas les mêmes acteurs et c'est pas
le même niveau qui nous parle donc
sans doute qu'il y a encore des des
décalages à faire de ce point de vue là
même si je sans doute que que c'est très
accessible également
effectivement sur cette année on voit
que les mobilisations sont bien plus
précoces au niveau des préfectures et
des comités de sécheresse pour mettre
tout le monde autour de la table et
partager les situations et voir quelles
actions pour mettre en œuvre voilà
peut-être un propos un peu un peu
périphérique mais d'abord je voudrais
dire que c'est assez difficile pour des
petits acteurs d'être présent dans
toutes les instances de concertation qui
sont quand même très très nombreuses
nous on essaie d'être dans les clés dans
les commissions locales de l'eau mais on
n'y arrive pas toujours enfin je vais
tout le monde ne peut pas n'importe quel
petit producteur peut pas prendre la
parole voilà passer une journée dans une
réunion voilà c'est assez compliqué
concrètement après il y en a quand même
un sujet puisque vous abordez la
gouvernance on a un sujet cohérence des
des politiques publiques à renforcer
nous alors c'est un petit peu différent
de la grande hydro effectivement un
petit hydro notre tutelle c'est la
direction de l'eau et donc on a pu
l'aborder ici à demain entreprises mais
on est on est donc vu comme un comme un
obstacle à la continuité écologique et
pas comme un outil de production
d'énergie renouvelable il ne porte pas
de grand intérêt à la production
d'énergie puisque c'est pas leur métier
donc là il faut enfin voilà si si on n'a
pas trouvé la solution encore mais je
cite un exemple la loi climat résilience
et le Sénat en été l'auteur pour cette
disposition avait les augmentations de
puissance et quand vous en parlez avec
la DDT et vous explique que vous pouvez
amender autant que vous voulez le code
de l'énergie mais tant qu'on amende pas
le code de l'environnement il bougeront
pas d'un pouce et donc ces augmentations
de puissance sont dans les faits
impossibles parce que côté environnement
ça bloque donc il y a un sujet
gouvernance évident mais je n'ai pas la
solution
je voudrais conforter ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est à dire que pour si on
revient à l'échelle des moulins on est
confronté actuellement à
la problématique de la restauration de
la continuité écologique voire de la
production d'hydrolelectricité où il y a
aucune instance de médiation d'écoute
etc c'est à dire que il y a un progrès
notoire avait l'agence à nogarone mais
ce n'est qu'un progrès mais d'une
manière générale il n'y a pas de lieu où
on peut effectivement
parler de l'expertise d'usage des
propriétaires des difficultés à financer
ne passe à poissons des difficultés
rencontrées par l'administration qui
résiste à toute idée de produire de
l'hydroélectricité d'installation
d'installer un système donc voilà là il
y a un vrai problème entre la personne
qui est dans un micro projet on est on
est bien d'accord et au niveau de
l'agence il n'y a pas de
représentativité donc c'est c'est encore
différent de ce que disait Jean-Marc
Lévy mais
encore beaucoup plus précis parce que on
se retrouve avec des personnes en
détresse c'est à dire que un professeur
de Moulins à qui on annonce qu'il va y
avoir une passe à poissons de 200 et
quelques mille euros qui va être
subventionné évidemment mais ce qu'il a
payé c'est une catastrophe bon je veux
pas être dans l'anecdote mais et ça il y
a pas de lieu de médiation pour en
discuter par exemple nous la Fédération
avec
sachant que adogarone est en train de
peut-être évoluer dans le bon sens
avant de conclure est-ce qu'il y a
peut-être un sujet ou un message
particulier que vous souhaiteriez faire
passer que nous n'aurions pas forcément
abordés
j'imagine nous laisser une petite phrase
de conclusion c'est ça chacun un petit
message non mais moi je pense qu'on a un
défi collectif qui est de mené de front
la transition écologique la transition
la transition énergétique et la gestion
durable de l'eau
l'hydroélectricité j'espère que c'est le
message qu'on a réussi à passer
aujourd'hui c'est que à un rôle
absolument clé à jouer parce que c'est
une partie importante de la solution moi
j'en suis convaincu et qu'on est
évidemment prêt à apprendre toute notre
part à ce à ce double défi
alors moi j'ai besoin d'une minute dans
mon premier message c'est d'abord que
notre modèle CNR nous apprend que la
gestion globale ou globalisée de l'eau
permet de mieux gérer les enjeux avec
l'ensemble des acteurs en partageant les
contraintes des objectifs de chacune des
parties qui peuvent d'ailleurs ça a été
dit un varier en fonction des lieux chez
nous aux différences entre le haut et le
Sud et les périodes de l'année et il est
important que ce ne soit pas celui qui
crie le plus fort qui est gain de cause
et que ce soit un travail
d'objectivation des enjeux et des
urgences qui le décident la question de
la gouvernance a été évoquée donc c'est
important et la place de l'État et des
élus dans cette gouvernance est
importante et au même titre qu'en 2003
et 2004 l'État et les régions ont su
traiter les questions des inondations
meurtrières sur le Rhône nous souhaitons
que l'État et les régions prennent toute
leur place et leur responsabilité dans
les tours de table et c'est un air en
tant que concessionnaire et gestionnaire
global du fleuve apportera sa capacité
d'expertise et son agilité dans
l'exploitation
mon deuxième message c'est que nous
devons rechercher à chaque fois que nous
le pouvons à optimiser l'eau et de ce
point de vue les installations au fil de
l'eau sont intéressantes 19 fois la même
goutte d'eau optimisée est toujours
rejetée et jamais prélevé mais dire que
cela mais ne cela ne veut pas dire que
dans ma bouche que j'opposerais une
forme d'optimisation rendue possible par
des retenues c'est pas ça que je veux
dire voilà le message essentiel que je
souhaitais vous passer en vous
remerciant de votre écoute et de votre
travail essentiel pour les acteurs de
l'hydrollectricité
de stress hydrique nécessite partage de
ressources
tension potentielle dont gouvernance a
affiner à l'image de ce que j'ai pu
indiquer quoi notamment dans les
situations d'urgence
forcément des curseurs qui doivent se
déplacer l'hydroélectricité majeur pour
le réseau mais le aussi importantes pour
le la gestion de l'eau
on
lâchait en tout cas est déterminée à
jouer un rôle dans ces deux parties là
il y a aussi à terme des modèles
économiques à réfléchir pour que tout ça
puisse être pérenne
dans des situations évidemment où les
prix de l'élecs ont diminué ce qui est
souhaitable et qui ne tardera pas à
venir
moi je dirais je rappellerai juste
quelque chose sur le coup sur quoi on
est passé assez vite mais donc
l'hydroélectricité c'est une énergie
renouvelable mais c'est surtout comme
vient de le dire Cyril une assurance
pour la transition énergétique et pour
les réseaux c'est une énergie qui est
vraiment complémentaire des autres
énergies renouvelables si l'hydro est
effectivement sensible aux variations
inter-annuelles de débit elle est en
revanche très prévisible très très
pilotable et très modulable au sein
d'une même année ça c'est important et
puis je voilà je rappelle mon propos
introductif on a on a un potentiel de
plus 20% en France et ce serait à mon
sens une grave erreur de ne pas le
développer
on s'inscrit bien sûr en totalité avec
ce que nous avons entendu sur les
bienfaits de l'hydroélectricité
simplement au niveau des moulins ce que
nous préconisons essentiellement c'est
d'équiper des sites existants c'est
facilement réalisable c'est disponible
tout de suite ça nécessite aucun
investissement sur les réseaux parce que
c'est des toutes petites puissances le
réseau va les absorber facilement c'est
très délocalisé donc il faut y aller
merci beaucoup pour vos interventions je
vais laisser le soin à notre président
de voyant vouloir conclure président
doyen par intérim oui merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup à vous tous en réalisant
vous avez été consulté pour les
stradettes évidemment vous avez apporté
votre pierre à l'église extradettes qui
vont jouer un rôle important dans la
transition énergétique et dans l'énergie
aussi future donc j'espère que ça a été
le cas en tous les cas merci beaucoup de
votre votre participation et de votre
éclairage on a bien compris que il faut
aller de l'avant il faut aller de
l'avant je sais pas si on y arrivera
mais non on est là aussi pour vous aider
parce que nous sommes les défenseurs des
territoires